et on en parle avec Armelle charrier
bonjour Armelle une contre-offensive qui
a donc l'air de bien avancer sur le
terrain qui avance absolument sur le
terrain même si il ne faut pas se voiler
la face c'est un temps important pour
les Ukrainiens qui mettent les moyens il
y a 300000 soldats qui seraient sur le
front face à 100000 russes mais pour
l'instant les gains territoriaux russes
n'ont pas pu être récupérés complètement
mais en tout cas ce qui est important de
souligner c'est que dans la région de
doniace qui n'a pas été complètement
prise par les Russes il y a à peu près
la moitié du territoire qui a été occupé
par les Russes les
Ukrainiens ont fait cette percée dans un
premier temps dimanche ils ont pris
cette ville de Liman qui est important
parce que c'est un euphorroviaire c'est
un routier et donc du coup ça permet
d'avancer et là ils ont avancé
effectivement constatant que les Russes
ne sont plus là qu'ils se sont reculés
donc ça leur permet du coup d'avancer et
de voir s'ils vont mettre davantage de
bataillon davantage d'artillerie voir
comment est-ce qu'ils vont se
positionner donc on a les yeux vers
cette ville de Liman sachant que et les
Ukrainiens continue aussi une offensive
qui est importante pour eux qui est plus
au sud complètement elle s'est dans la
ville de Quinson puisqu'ils veulent
récupérer effectivement la ville de
Carson là pour l'instant les Russes
n'ont pas envisagé de partir et
concrètement les Russes on voit qu'ils
sont très clairement regroupés autour de
toute la région de louance vous savez
que ça c'est un noblesse qu'ils ont
conquis complètement il y a après il y a
eu le référendum et donc c'est quelque
chose qui a l'air assez assuré
militairement et donc pour l'instant on
les voit se replier dans trop dans
toutes ces zones là et stratégique dans
le cadre de cette contre-offensive
ukrainienne on le sait l'aide militaire
internationale la France entre autres a
annoncé l'envoi de nouvelles armes oui
parce que c'est un moment important pour
les Ukrainiens comme je vous le disais
ils sont avides de victoire ils sont
plus nombreux mais ils ont des
territoires à récupérer et que pour
l'instant proportionnellement ils ont
récupéré peu de territoires par rapport
à ce qui avait pris les Russes et ils
ont donc besoin d'armement pour pouvoir
effectuer toutes ces j'allais dire sévit
ses avancées militaires et la France
leur avait fourni à des cadences César
on avait beaucoup parlé 18 maintenant on
parlerait de leur en redonner entre 6 à
12 qui c'était normalement prévu de
d'être livré au Danemark et donc on les
prendrait entre temps et on récupérerait
aussi des blindés qui eux appartiennent
à arcus qui est un des industriels
français qui ne sont pas en dotation
dans l'armée française que généralement
on exporte on en voulant les pays
africains et qui sont donc des véhicules
qui permettent d'embarquer une dizaine
de personnes à l'intérieur et donc du
coup assez assez bien protégé c'est
important parce que très vite on va
avoir une période qui va être une
période où il va pleuvoir où il va y
avoir énormément de boue et que donc du
coup les combats vont s'arrêter donc les
ce qui peut être gagné maintenant sera
conservé forcément sinon il faut que ce
soit délivré au moment de l'hiver quand
les sols sont gelés quand il y a de la
neige
pas la période qu'il a plus propice mais
au moins ça permet quand même d'autres
manœuvres merci beaucoup Armel pour
votre